good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday hope everyone is
having a blessed day thus far we're
about to bless your day even thus
further hello Jax how are you doing I am
darn good thank you so much it's a
gorgeous Tuesday so joyful can't wait to
Rejoice with you in the glory that is
Tuesday glory be the god amen sister
how was your Monday
it was Monday it wasn't terrible you
know it was a nice ease into the week
we're back Tuesday now we're in it rise
grind hustle you know you know I had a
nice Monday myself I finished my book
which was very good I would say though
that the first half was much better than
the second half the second half was a
little rush and like the inventory
things they just weren't Landing for me
but it's a true story so it's like it
seemed unbelievable if it wasn't a true
story I'd be like this could never
happen but because it's a true story I'm
like tell me more ma'am
are we going to talk
about
your sweatshirt about my sweatshirt yeah
thank you for reminding me because you
know I would have forgotten even though
we spoke about it four seconds before we
started recording right which is why it
was out of my mind I always come on the
show with like a couple things and I
want to say do I ever remember to say
them no but this is so you should write
them down I should I really should I
need more like that's what I put in
paper around my house she just right
gotta start jotting things down errant
thoughts errant thoughts but today's
announcement is that redhead's merch is
dropping new merch I've been teasing it
for a while but I really wanted to get
everything so gorgeous and right for you
guys because the redheads is like an
ironclad brand and there's just no room
for error period zero today I'm wearing
one of our new sweatshirts from the
collection if you're watching on YouTube
I'm just gonna move to the left if
you're listening as a podcast check out
our Instagram because we will have
posted a photo in the sweatshirt
it's really cute you know the redheads
are kind of evolving the redheads are
babbling so we will be dropping like
four sweatshirts one long sleeve a hat
tote bag as always phone case mugs you
can see the whole collection on our
Instagram account I will post all of the
images of things that we're dropping and
the redheads are constantly evolving and
I I thank you for bringing that up
because not only do we always evolve and
with every book that we read we are
expanding our minds but we're also
always growing I know I joke around
about how the redheads are taking over
the world but it's like kind of not a
joke
when do you think you'll get to the
place where like your emblem is on the
cover of a book
if I ever reprint my book which I don't
know why I would you know what when I
did the paperback I should have done it
I should have because I got the New York
Times emblem which is really why I did
the paperback I should have done the
redheads one like what's wrong with me I
think that to be honest it won't happen
because
I'm pretty sure that like Reese's book
club Oprah Jenna's book club they get
Advanced copies of books and they choose
what book They're gonna have for a
specific month before the book is
released so then when the book is
released they can put on the cover that
it's a Jenna's book club it's a today
show you know it's a Reese and the
redheads we're just lay people who are
just recommending books that we think
would be good and so we'll never be on
the ground floor like that I mean I
guess we could be if we got like but
that's not the spirit of the redheads
because nobody reads the books before we
choose them yeah so I don't know if that
would happen but you guys know my goal
for the redheads like where I would be
like okay we made it is to have a
redheads table of books at like Barnes
and Noble or a local Bookshop store I
mean I could show up with a table myself
and kind of I feel like we definitely
have a toaster who is like a manager at
a Barnes Noble a local Indie bookstore
um and if you do that like we'll promote
the hell out of your store so the hell
the hell so I feel like it's a win-win
for everyone agreed reach out to me if
you have the power to set up a table in
your local bookstore it's so funny how
we have like such Niche goals like when
not even for books but like when I was
releasing my book like I really wanted
to be sold in airports and that was
um a goal that I achieved and like a lot
of people obviously I wanted to be in
New York Times bestseller all that thing
but we have like such random Niche goals
when it comes to our career yeah no and
but it's also just things that you
associate with making it do you know
what I mean yeah and I think it's almost
like we're not like other career women
of course but I think it's different for
everyone because you know we all grew up
differently and you would see things as
a sign of success and to me like going
to a bookstore and seeing a table that's
like Reese's book club which they have
I'm like why not redheads
why now why now why this sperm so
redheads merge impertinent information
is dropping Thursday we're Thursday
girls over at the redhead so this
Thursday redheads merch is dropping at
shopmorningtoast.com check out at the
redheads on Instagram for all the
details and the great thing about the
redheads is like if you are a redhead
you can rep the brand love it but if
you're like not even a redhead you could
still like rip it and people are like
what's that and you're like it's my book
club and they're like smart Tings no but
then if you happen to have red hair it
just also adds another element you know
yeah it's multifaceted
um would love that for you love love to
see you know literate women thriving and
being fashionable that's really all you
want to see from women literacy and
fashion and the redheads achieves both
speaking of redheads you are still
reading lessons in chemistry I know
you're struggling a little bit yeah it's
it's a fine book it's really not an
amazing book like I just want to be
totally honest I'm about 70 like I could
have finished it last night but I'm like
I'm not even having a good time it's you
know me I read a book in a day so it's
taken me like six different reading
sessions to finish it it's fine it's a
good book it's like whatever but are you
not obsessed with 6 30 and mad I was not
really I I was like them together the
character development of the main
character Elizabeth is so horrendous I
want to smack her upside the [ __ ]
head
um like you of this once in a lifetime
opportunity somebody literally came to
you gave you a TV show at a prime slot
you literally like I've never worked in
TV in your life and you're gonna be an
ungrateful wench that's what you're
gonna be and I get it it's for women's
empowerment I get it but it's like stop
stop follow the rules and I know in the
end it works out because she did it her
way I get it but watching her like
destroy everything in her path just to
like do it her way
it's kind of you know Annoying the [ __ ]
out of me damn we needed you on the
redheads episode because we were all
agreeing
no like I get it women are more than
houses set in the 50s I believe in the
message I agree with you that like there
needs to be some compromise like just
because things should be done a certain
way doesn't mean that they're going to
and it can't be my way or the highway or
else we're never getting anywhere yeah I
did just get to the part in the book
where her and Mrs frass laid down their
arms because they share a mutual trauma
and I loved that so much like justice
for Mrs frass like no wonder she was
like a miserable wench like she's been
treated like [ __ ] yeah that was dating
his takeaway Frost was her favorite
frask was a queen
and then frass getting fired for being
27 pounds overweight like relatable
so there are elements of the book that I
do enjoy but overall like as a read I'm
not finding it like to be a super easy
read it's not and we get it it's not
working in science I cannot deal with
the pages and pages of scientific
references like this did I pick up a
textbook
uh like on the cooking show how she
can't just say salt she has to say NaCl
you know stop
stop stop she's annoying the [ __ ] out of
me she's not your kind of girl she's
like quirky you know yeah and she's you
know what she is
she scrupled to a fault
at times
I couldn't have said it better myself I
couldn't have said about it myself
um
we have a Fab show not a ton of uh TV
recap which is great so we're just going
to be able to focus on the stories focus
on ourselves which is so important when
you have a podcast to focus on yourself
oh Beyond especially when it's every day
and you guys see yeah everything that I
was doing and speaking you know what I
made it to the gym yesterday I'm feeling
hush oh wow good for you
you know there's a trend going around on
Tick Tock that I wanted to get your take
on it's like people are sharing the
moments in media and pop culture that
like shifted who they were as a person
and I was curious if you had any moments
like that definitely for me obviously
one that comes to mind is Ariana Grande
performing at the wicked 15-year
anniversary like that performance like
really truly shifted
who I was as a woman
yeah I feel like for me I need to back
it up a little further
because I feel like
when I'm younger that's when you know
you're more impressionable and these
things have a way of Shifting you
shifting streisands or like a moment in
a TV show
no need to think about it because I
don't wanna I don't wanna
I think I can think of big moments from
our childhood that we're like oh my God
and like the whole world was talking
about a certain thing like Miley Cyrus
on the cover of Vanity Fair but that's a
good one for I don't know that that
shifted things for me
for me it made me realize my God people
will complain about anything yeah
another one of those moments really have
to do with Miley Cyrus
okay so another one of my moments is
Desperate Housewives like when tom
leaves Lynette like who the [ __ ] do you
think you are you [ __ ] wench yeah
after all she's done for you and your
dumb ass opening the pizzeria like that
was a moment and I was like Wow men are
really like they have the audacity like
they have the audacity yeah she gave her
gave up her career for you even though
she was more successful than you so she
could be a housewife and you could
continue to work
you then put the family's livelihood at
stake by opening that dumbass Pizzeria
the scabbos
and then you leave her you [ __ ] wench
yeah if you really related to Lynette
um even more so I didn't relate to her
but I sympathized with her yeah even
more so when I rewatched the show as a
grown woman because you know being in a
relationship and being married like you
know marriage is all about compromise
and
you really saw as like a grown woman how
much nerve Tom skavo had just because he
was like better looking of the two
interesting take I rewatched Desperate
Housewives almost like eight years ago
now so not as like a white fresh and
definitely and not as a mom I feel like
my time might be coming the only thing
is that now I don't have the time
make the time it'll like it's there's
actually so many moments from Desperate
Housewives that like where major life
altering moments for me when Carlos
became blind
that was huge or like when Orson
when Orson like had to be kicked out of
the house because like he had in you
know a few years ago run over Mike and
it's like but Orson and Brie
right
no there's some that really that show is
so good like I feel sympathy and sadness
for anyone who's never seen it yeah no I
feel actually really excited for you
guys because it's all ahead of you
it's all happening in the words of
Sheena Marie Shea yeah that's a good
trend on Tick Tock I need to think about
it further to think about like what
really resonated with me
sound off in the comments like what was
a moment in pop culture and media that
really like changed who you were as a
young woman or man
another moment was Caitlyn Jenner's
special Diane oh that actually like
changed my perspective on life like that
was the first time many people
yeah and not even of course about like
trans but also like now when I'm like
talking to people about like gender
which I don't really do all that often
but like if I if I do like I'm always
saying how you know gender and sexuality
are so different and I only learn that
from the Caitlyn Jenner special like
when Caitlyn said that I was like oh my
God yeah duh like the two have nothing
to do with one like it really
um that was a cultural shift that was a
cultural shift and yes it was very
educational in terms of like the
transgender experience I think for so
many people but something else that I
really took away from it is to mind the
way we speak about people who uh-huh no
because you don't know what's going on
could be anything and the way that
people were talking about Caitlyn for
that special like it just didn't get any
nastier nastier than what was being said
and we were all a part of it
100 we are all guilty and compliant that
was a horrible time so that was a big
eye-opening moment for me
yeah no that's a good one too
um I'm curious to hear what people are
gonna say because people sharing a lot
of people have like moments from TV
shows that I don't watch like fleabag
um but it's been really interesting to
see like what what stays with people I
think for a lot of people Marissa Cooper
dying was how they like that yes yes yes
yes yes
that's a good one too
um so yeah just like a fun fun thing the
kids are doing on the talk I thought I
would alert you to yeah that's cool
thanks yeah thanks for keeping me up
with the kids that's really my job here
at the toast to kind of be like the Gen
Z correspondent because you know I kind
of Teeter between being gen Z and
millennial
yeah
sure
um we're also gearing up for our toast a
ween episode next week we're gonna be
together I just finally booked my
flights to come see you I'm going to
join you at the end of this week and
then all of next week will be together
for episodes and of course we're gonna
end the week uh with toastaween what day
is it is toasting like what day is it I
think Halloween oh actually Halloween is
on Monday oh so will we do it Monday
that looks so weird yeah no we're doing
it Monday that is weird because usually
we might leave it all at the end of the
week and then Friday and come back
Monday it's November and we're first no
but starting off the week with uh toast
to eat episode is going to be kind of
bizarre now it will be but that's we're
not like it's the 31st
we adhere to the lunar calendar we
do and that's just a little bit about us
so stay tuned for that some people have
been guessing I have not seen anyone
guess what we're going to be which is I
love to shuck and awe yeah I don't think
I've seen anyone guess it uh right I'm
truly excited I don't think so
um and yeah that's really all it for me
was an uneventful day not much to update
the girlies on slept like a beast oh
oh sorry
so I'm sleeping
Heavenly slumber
all of a sudden I hear
now in case you couldn't tell that was
glass shattering couldn't tell
glass shattered on the white cloth I'm
like what the [ __ ]
so right before bed Ben is like I want
to go get some water and I had just
filled I have like a reusable water
bottle that I use because I've been
trying to drink a lot of water it's
always on my nightstand
I drink I drink a lot of water
it's always filled with ice and Brita
like it's really premium so Ben's like
I'm gonna go get some water I'm like no
wait I just filled mine up here take my
thing he's like no no I might just take
it you don't have to get up take my
water he's like no I really like those
cups you got in Rome like I wanna just
like use the cup I'm like okay cut to
four in the morning Ben's like being a
beast in his sleep and he knocks the the
cup off the table and shatters my
[ __ ]
brand new glass I went to Rome I bought
eight water glasses that are so cute I
literally got them home I was carrying
these glasses it was like such a thing
I've kept them all intact since I went
to Rome in October Ben boom breaks one
in the middle of the night so then
there's glass all over the floor he has
to vacuum because Theo and it's
literally I'm so [ __ ] pissed in my
sleep I didn't even get up but I was
like I guess I was yelling at bed in my
sleep about how I literally tricked
through all of Europe with these glasses
just for him to come home and break it
and be a beast
so then I woke up like normal time a few
hours later and I had a text from Ben
um he had found the glasses on Wolf and
Badger you ever get to see that website
really cute stuff really cute stuff he
had found them he bought me a new set of
eight which was so nice because he only
broke one
um but I guess like in his sleep he had
felt really bad because I literally
begged him right before bed not to use
the glass like just use my [ __ ] water
bottle [ __ ]
so I have eight new glasses on their way
will you come out on top
I do it's just like
it's just like like why like just use
the water bottle of course
just use a water bottle he had to be all
special and Fancy Fancy Nancy Fancy
Nancy over here yeah
yeah and it Disturbed my sleep which
like unboxing just as much as the cup
and I'm sure Theo was just stressed as
hell we all woke up kind of like in a
tizzy like we were frazzled
it you hate to see it it was really
disrespectful
he'll have to apologize for that yeah
he'll have to he did by the way like he
felt really bad which just made me even
more annoyed because I wanted to be
angry right right you can't be angry at
someone who's like deeply apologetic and
he woke up he was like I should have
just taken the water bottle I'm like yes
like he knew exactly I'm like but I
still wanted to be angry see now you
need to like hold on to this memory for
the next time he tries to defy you and
be like remember what happened last time
yes that's called being petty yeah
that's called big Penny that's also I
feel like what you would do with Harry
like to teach someone a lesson yeah I
that perhaps
speaking of eggplant roladini how is my
son he's great he misses his auntie
but he's been great he's left us with a
little present today a little spit up on
myself my new merch mommy's new merch no
big deal let's talk about baby spit up
because the way it smells so
unbelievably vile I mean of course it's
throw up so that makes sense but the
older he gets the more disgusting it
gets because in the beginning it was
just like a little breast milk you know
finding the opposite like no he threw
spit up on me today but he had had
oatmeal for breakfast and it actually
smelled like like cute baby Tings it
didn't smell vile today maybe it's
because you're like his mom but like it
is literally a church it's like it could
make me gag the smell oh my God you are
so dramatic I'm not dramatic at all okay
I'm not like it's so smelly
now tell me you said that
please do
think about me enrolled we have a really
honest relationship with one another who
says Auntie you look fat in those genes
I say roldini your breath stinks his
breath has never smelled a day in his
life no not his breath actually that's
the thing about like not having teeth is
your breath smells incredible yeah gotta
knock out all my teeth
so sick of having bad breath yeah
I like have bad breath I think I have a
cavity
I need to go to the dentist too one
thing about me is like I'm not going to
the dentist you know yeah I have to go I
don't have strong teeth so it's
imperative that I do go but I think
you're fine
and you know what like remember when we
were kids and like everyone got to the
phase in their life where they were
getting braces and it was like the worst
thing to happen to your social life like
it was literally crippling to be just
like metal mouth Mabel and now so many
people I know like in their adulthood
who had braces
are doing Invisalign and just like
Invisalign is so common like kids these
days like don't even need to get metal
braces like they're getting Invisalign
like that's not fair this line is so
expensive and honestly for a kid you're
getting braces is it not covered by
insurance or braces I guess it's
cosmetic and braces I think are we never
had them I don't know the cost right I
don't know so much less expensive than
Invisalign yeah no but I feel like we'll
get to a place where like Invisalign
becomes the norm perhaps but I think
right now if a kid needs braces like
you're getting braces deal with it yeah
no that's like that's one part of like
like I always wish to be younger for
sure but like that whole braces thing
like that was a traumatizing part of
Youth for a lot of people yeah you know
what I was thinking about recently
because I feel like so many people
especially like influencers and
celebrities like have veneers
okay I was thinking about that too
because our teeth are not veneers like
we think we have bad teeth no no not
that I think I have bad teeth but it's
like I just like don't look like a grown
person because I have like my little
Chiclet teeth by the way I completely
agree and then like grown women have
veneers and I guess I'm like I'm not
grown until I have veneers no I was
literally have I was just thinking about
this because I saw a tick tock of the
sky was like do not get veneers he was
like bleeding out of his mouth and all
the comments were like about how
celebrity and influencer culture is like
totally normalized getting veneers
cosmetically for no reason whereas like
you used to get a veneer or a set of
veneers if your teeth got knocked out
like it was a medical thing and now it's
just like a total vanity thing how like
yes you are not like beautiful until you
have veneers and it's [ __ ] yeah it's
so I never thought about it before and I
always would have thought that like you
get veneers if your natural teeth aren't
great but more like you need like you
chip a tooth or something right right
but now I'm like am I just never gonna
be on that level if I don't have veneers
I just want to say I don't really feel
bad for you because in terms of adult
teeth your teeth are cut like I could
look you and be like wait does she have
veneers like you have like not your
bottom teeth no offense but your topped
but your top teeth are like grown adult
teeth I have two buck front teeth then
the ones next to it are tiny little
Chiclets and then the ones next to those
are vampire Bella Swan things like I
have like real teeth whereas like you
have like beautiful teeth your top teeth
thank you yes I'm not getting veneers I
never even
thought about it but I just was like
noticing all
of the influencers and celebrities have
been years and I'm like maybe I'll like
it it's it just looks so much more
mature no and the crazy thing about
veneers is like how common they've
become when they're literally 30 grand
and so painful and like to get installed
do they take out you have no teeth
underneath you have like little Nubs
they pull out they have to shave it down
to put the cap on
it's like a crazy thing to do no thank
you and one thing about me like I
embrace plastic surgery cosmetic
enhancements but I draw the line at
teeth
unnecessarily
of course
like I'm not talking about when Sheena
tripped on the sidewalk sued the city
and was able to get a whole new set of
teeth yeah
it's just interesting no I'm so glad you
brought that up because people were just
talking about it on Tick Tock I'm like
you're right it's so weird yeah and I
just feel like at every like people
eventually always get veneers I feel
like how many like older people do you
see with their with their teeth that
grew in when they were eight
no one
but that's going to be me I'm not
getting veneers I'll watch this episode
in two years with my big new teeth and
be like oh I was so naive
no I really
um like yeah every single person on
reality TV has veneers yeah and I just
feel like now like it's kind of how when
everyone gets like lip injections but I
have these are my like natural lips but
now it's like I'm kind of part of the
small lipped Community because
everybody's lipstick no you're not
nobody because that's how like the
scale is changing yes yes it says but
that's why like when Sonya Morgan oh my
tooth fell out like it's not her real
tooth you know what I mean yeah
veneers fall out all the time so
interesting
so interestant
um such your dental news of the day and
while we could speak about teeth all
morning we have work to do so without
further but you know what wait you know
what I have um
I've got beef between my teeth it would
be like
us do without my floss that's like the
that is a cultural shift in media like
that episode of Suite Life of Zack and
Cody where that kids perform the song
and that kid happened to be Justin from
Ugly Betty
wow and he did that little dance
I've got beef because he was pretending
to be a piece of floss it was so good
also we went to the moon in 1969
cultural shift
did anybody reset for that no because I
had thought that it was 1970 but it was
the year sooner yeah I didn't know that
now you know
so now without further Ado it is time
for the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your take a bite out
of your toast oh
today's episode is brought to you by
fashion pass thank you fashion pass for
sponsoring today's episode we know so
many toasters already know and love
fashion pass because it is the steeniest
clothing rental service where you get
unlimited rentals for one flat price
their clothes are everything of the sort
and in my opinion would separate them
from other clothing rental services
where you're gonna get tunics that your
grandmother would wear no there's so
they're renting things that are actually
current they are hot right now you can
find some of their pieces on revolve
currently being sold
you're saving so much money because
you're not buying out new clothes every
time you have an event a baby shower a
wedding no it's just like rent it girl
rent it and it's so much more
sustainable better for the environment
and better for your wallet the brands
that they carry are premium they have
for love and lemons free people show me
your MooMoo you guys know we're obsessed
with show me your MooMoo and Amanda up
Richard if you hate spending 200 on an
outfit that you're going to wear on
vacation or to brunch take a picture in
and never wear again check out the
trendsetter plan that's what Jackie and
I are on we get to pick three clothing
items and two accessories for every
order and then we can switch out our
items as many times a month as we want
the shipping is super fast they take
care of dry cleaning and everything for
you so you send it back you don't have
to wash it and then you know when you're
getting something it has been dry
cleaned for you they give you a bag to
ship it in so when you're done it's just
super easy and then you can choose new
items one of our favorite Parts is that
if you love something so much that you
actually want to buy it you can do that
you can buy something directly from
Fashion pass and you're going to get a
huge discount somewhere between 30 and
60 off it's super better option than
traditional shopping and it's more
sustainable if you're not into renting
but you just want to purchase something
you can actually buy anything on their
site now even if you're not a member
they offer free shipping and returns
it's super easy and you could purchase
brand new items or like new items for
huge discounts up to 70 off which is
amazing we have a special discount code
for you today if you go to
fashionpass.com use code toast at
checkout you'll get 40 off your first
month so you can try it for literally 39
it's unlimited rentals for just 39 with
code toast I feel like people when they
start fashion pass like they're
extremely grateful to us because like if
you don't know about it it'll change
your life because clothing rental is so
genius but a lot of these rental sites
just have like fugly clothing like it's
so ugly and it's not for like everyday
wear you know you know what it's not for
like honestly The Toasters who are like
extremely stylish yeah it's for special
occasions mostly but like I struggle
most with everyday wear getting dressed
yes every single day I mean how many
times have I worn this cardigan also I
think the best way to shop is to rent
something from somewhere see if you wear
it how you wore it if you liked it and
then keep it if it's meant for you
totally
um so thank you fashion pass for
sponsoring today's episode we also are
sponsored by framebridge the Custom
Framing company that will change your
opinion of what true customization
really is they measure and handcraft
each frame specifically for your piece
so you can frame Bridge just about
anything selfies Game Day Jerseys your
anniversary dinner menu or your latest
artistic Masterpiece go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo if
you have a physical piece to frame
they'll send you a complimentary
packaging that you can safely mail it
into I feel like the most genius part of
framebridge is like literally from your
phone I take so many premium pictures on
my phone I feel like the only pictures I
use to frame are like wedding photos or
photographer photos why like I have so
many gorgeous photos of myself of my
family of ruraldini that I take on my
phone and being able to upload directly
from your phone throw a little Jackie O
flow on it it's so premium it's so easy
and it's genius and it's so affordable
like framing is so crazy expensive like
for what right for wood I feel like
sometimes I look at Art and I'm like or
frame photographs and I'm like I could
have taken that picture and then
sometimes they take a picture and I'm
like am I gray Malin so right I was
actually just on framebridge and looking
through my phone because I am going to
frame a photo that I've taken I'm not
sure which one yet but I need some more
art Decor around my house and I feel
like I've had so many pictures that I've
taken on like National Geographic no
literally so how it works is you'll
upload your photo you can preview your
item in dozens of their frame styles and
you can choose your favorite or get um
help from a designer for free the
experts at framebridge custom frame your
item deliver your finished piece right
to your door and instead of paying
hundreds at a framing store framebridge
starts at just 39 and free shipping you
can order online
or stop or stop by a framebridge store
near you to work with a designer in
person so they've been popping up all
over the country check to see if there's
a framebridge store near you if not you
can go online they're both super easy
we've both done it you have a gorgeous
photo of yourself framed in your closet
right that you took like on your phone
Zach took it so it's really like of both
of us it's showing his creative eye and
my gorgeous stunning face
um frame your photos send someone the
perfect gift at framebridge.com that's
framebridge.com
thank you mclartia you're welcome for
all the links and all the codes that'll
save
gotta add a shoulder to it you better
okay our first story is kind of [ __ ]
wild James Corden is Hollywood's latest
tantrum maker so yes tantrum thrower
yesterday Keith McNally NYC posted on
Instagram he is the owner of Balthazar
and pastis and mirandi and Minetta
Tavern he's a restaurant tour and those
are all like if you don't live in New
York those are all like celeb hot spots
like I believe him when he's saying man
at a Tavern like these are all premium
like good luck getting a table at any of
these restaurants yes so he posted a
grainy photo of James Corden he really
dragged him to filth with that photo
looks like he took it on his phone of
Google Images you know when people oh my
God
out of nowhere he said James Corden is a
hugely gifted comedian but a tiny cretan
of a man and not the word Creighton and
the most abusive customer to my
Balthazar server since the restaurant
opened 25 years ago I don't off an 86 a
customer to today I 86 Cordon it did not
make me laugh here are two examples of
the funny man's treatment on my staff
manager report number one in June James
Corden was here on table 61. although
this is diabolical diabolical it happens
very occasionally in all restaurants
after eating his main course Gordon
showed the hair to buy health is our
manager G who is very apologetic Gordon
was extremely nasty to G and said quote
get us another round of drinks this
second and also take care of all of our
drinks this far this way I write any
nasty reviews in Yelp or anything like
that
okay so obviously you know getting a
hair in your food is not ideal but like
humans are creating your food and
sometimes that happens and it's gross
but the restaurant especially a fancy
place like Balthazar like they'll always
make it right they'll comp your meal
like right they'll make it right if you
point it out so obviously it's
unfortunate and it's on the restaurant
but that's what happens we're not robots
making your meal like people have hair
right manager report number two James
Corden was at Balthazar with his wife on
October 9th for brunch she asked for a
table outside brunch Mater D Ali Walters
took the party to table 301. Mr corden's
wife ordered an egg yolk omelet with
gruyere cheese and salad a few minutes
after they received the food James
called their server MK and told her
there was a little bit of egg white
mixed with the egg yolk MK informed the
floor manager G the kitchen remade the
dish but unfortunately sent it with home
fries instead of salad that's when James
Corden began yelling like crazy to the
server quote you can't do your job you
can't do your job maybe I should go into
the kitchen and cook The Omelette myself
MK was very apologetic and brought G
over to the table he returned the dish
and after that everything was fine he
gave them promo champagne glasses to
smooth things out G said that Gordon was
pleasant to him but nasty to the server
MK was very shaken of a professional
that she is continued to finish her
shift
okay so like
James Corden is like a monster
um I feel like that's not the most
surprising I think that that is
surprising
James I don't know like I can see it I
can see it no I'm really really
surprised he seems like
first of all his brand is being you know
that nice funny guy he's everybody's
friend in Hollywood and so was Ellen so
it was yeah no but that's why that was
shocking unless you had heard The
Whispers before yeah it's shocking
because her brand was being like the
nice funny woman she ended every show
like don't forget to be kind right but
she forgot don't you forget to be kind
so she totally escaped her mind I never
heard anything like this about James
Corden no whisper so this has caught me
unawares and it's very surprising
because it's very off-brand for what he
purports to be but then the manager also
or the owner also posted this another
granny photo of James Corden taken on
his phone from Google Images James
Corden just called me and apologized
profusely having [ __ ] up myself more
than most people I strongly believe in
second chances so if James Corden lets
me host his Late Late Show for nine
months I'll immediately rescind his band
from Balthazar no of course not but
anyone magnanimous enough to apologize
to a deadbeat layabout like me and my
staff doesn't deserve to be banned from
anywhere especially both as ours so come
back to the five and dime Jimmy Corden
Jimmy Corden All Is Forgiven
I feel like James Corden I will never
set foot in this restaurant ever again
it was nice of him to apologize I mean
he literally had no choice people were
dragging him to filth and like I feel
like this might this might be like the
beginning of the peeling back the layers
of James Corden well I think now if
other people have experiences like this
they will come forward I just
one I just before I say the next day I
just want to say I think people who are
nasty to wait sap are the nastiest
people most disgusting there was a bit
of egg white in your yolk like that's
not a real you're welcome it's healthier
for you yeah right no I completely agree
like that's psychotic behavior and and
and okay a hair in your food like yes
you definitely send that back but there
is a nicer way to do it no one put it
there intentionally calm the hook down
agreed people who have disrespect for
like servers are scum of the earth yes
with that said
this restaurant owner just like posting
a picture of James Corden to his
Instagram with like all of this
information I find to be extremely
bizarre like one if he's like we could
do more like a normal person yeah and
two like I feel like other celebrities
might be like well I don't know that I
want to go not because I'm a bad person
or anything but this guy's just like
putting people on blast you know
like yeah but I feel like this is not a
pattern with this man like if he was
doing it a lot I'd be like okay that's
weird but you know what like I don't
know I kind of liked it yeah I mean it's
t t no but it's also like you know what
you were gonna rolled out for sure
celebrities should live in fear that if
they're going to be rude to wait staff
like they're gonna get dragged because
I'm sorry you have to be a human being
that's true you know what like if this
instills the fear and God of the to the
Ellens of the world you know what I'm
[ __ ] here for it I am that's a good
point
it doesn't bother me normally like this
call out culture where like you know the
thing that always comes to mind it's
like the instacart driver who said like
Kylie's baby was screaming in the Next
Room like that [ __ ] I don't like because
one it feels like an invasion of privacy
and two it's like I don't know if I
believe you like do you where what's the
proof that you really even drive
instacart but this guy like I believe I
believe him I know he owns these
restaurants he's looking out for his
staff and you know what I'm here for it
okay
I am
because you know what like
celebrities are there are a lot of
celebrities who are like really really
rude to the people who work for them but
you know like those people have a choice
you know like they can you don't have to
work for Mariah Carey I mean I'll tell
you Mariah's carries evil you know like
you go to work as a server you're just
doing your job trying to wait on people
and you have to wait on some [ __ ]
like
you know what I I'm here for this whole
story
I I I don't disagree with you and I do I
like your point that they should live in
fear and they should be extra nice they
should live in fear end up
being like this but right remember when
Kendall Jenner left Mercer kitchen
without tipping or without paying the
bill
I remember there was a mercer kitchen
incident
um
I'm sure that it was an accident a
misunderstanding her friend was like I
got it no I got it and then they like I
don't think she skips out on bills and
the way that she was dragged till the
next Century online she'll never do it
again yeah
it teaches celebs
Everyone's Watching at all times if
you're gonna go out in public you can't
act like an ass yeah and that's a proper
ass it's good to promote people not
acting like an ass
agreed especially in restaurants because
I feel like wait staff are some of the
most
underappreciated and disrespected people
in this country
yeah
so like when I'm at a restaurant and I
hear so I'll never I feel like I've told
the story before I will never forget
like I I see people being rude all the
time nail salons too like my literal my
butt clenches I'm like yes make it stop
okay so I was at 40 carats I remember
the story from high school because I
happen to like have not like well really
well but I knew the girl who I was
looking at like are you sitting with
friends no no no no no okay she was a
few tables away like I didn't know her
enough to say hi but like I knew her
name you know in high school like you
used to like know people's names that
you didn't actually know Facebook
Facebook right okay and so we were at 40
carats and like at 40 carats they don't
write things down
um but they always get it right it's
like a thing there it's crazy they never
write down your order everyone
customizes a salad swap out this add
this but they always get it right
so this girl was a few tables down for
me and her salad arrived and I guess it
was incorrect and so she summons the
waiter and she like goes with her hands
like this she goes
generally I do not like it when waiters
don't write things down this salad is
incorrect she shoves it in his face
please return it
it was so rude like I and I we were both
like 16 at the time and I was like damn
she has [ __ ] balls [ __ ] like I would
never talk to anyone like that like at
six I've never talked to anyone like
that period but like at 16 like oh my
God I never forgot it I literally will
quote it once a week generally I don't
like when people don't write things down
oh man you have to tell me who it was
offline I would love to I don't know if
you know her oh my God that's like I
barely knew her she was just friends
with one of my friends also like my
salad has to be like a hamburger in
order for me to send it back
right of course of course you say no
croutons the croutons are there but you
just eat it you pick them out like it's
not a big deal like good I was hoping
they would be there
right no like for me I'll I'll never in
my life send things better I will
literally move things around go home and
Order McDonald's like I my husband will
send things back he'll be like you know
this fish doesn't taste right and like I
get it because you know you're paying
for a fish and if the fish is rotten
like you shouldn't eat it but like I
can't and if I ever do like my voice is
so small and no and this is what I say I
always whenever I'm like about to
complain at a restaurant I'm like I
realize I'm the most annoying human
being on the planet but like the salad
was supposed to not have dressing and it
has dressing so can I just get a new one
please yeah I guess if it was dressed
and I want it not dressed I would um for
me I think salad dressing is the most
disgusting thing on the planet if it's
anywhere near my salad I can't eat it
yeah yeah that would that's a salad and
that's for the salad that I eat once a
year so it's not really a frequent
problem that I have right
but no also I I like I just feel like in
general like say like something's like a
little amiss about your order whatever
it is
for the most part everyone should just
get a little more comfortable like
yeah it doesn't have to be Perfection
unless it's like something major like
I agree like I didn't want lettuce on my
burger take it off
[Music]
take it off right
have you like most nine times out of ten
what's wrong with your order you could
pick it out with your fingers like for
no yes I totally agree unless it's
really mixed in there chopped sauteed
and fried like you're fine yeah or like
it tastes good this way too you're like
you'll like it totally
anyways I'm very curious to hear if like
more people now have the stories about
Mr Gordon because you're not rude just
once it's a pattern yeah so
but that was surprising that was
speaking of people speaking out Jason
Sudeikis and Olivia was Wild's ex nanny
is telling all she gave an exclusive to
the Daily Mail and told how smitten
Olivia Wilde broke up with devastated
Jason Sudeikis just weeks after she
began filming don't worry darling with
Harry Styles in Palm Springs so before
we dive into this story I want to say
like I will be drinking up all the tea
that was spilled and dissecting every
minute of it but I think someone working
in your home with your children than
doing an anonymous interview is so
abhorrent and disgusting and such an
invasion of privacy I don't know if she
had an NDA if she didn't have NDA but
you let someone into your home with your
children and they exploit that like I
think that is so horrible and disgusting
and just scum scummy horrible disgusting
and I also just you know before I even
go to like what she said I want to let
you know that Jason and Olivia already
put out a statement
this might be the thing to bring them
back together because like they were
United against one another but now
someone who was in their home with their
children is attacking them it doesn't
even matter what they're saying like
they are now a united front they're back
to being a family yeah so they said
together as parents it is incredibly
upsetting to learn that a former nanny
of our two young children would choose
to make such false and scurrilous
accusations about us publicly her um
her now 18 month long campaign of
harassing us as well as loved ones close
friends and colleagues has reached its
unfortunate Apex we will continue to
focus on raising and protecting our
children with the sincere hope that she
will now choose to leave our family
alone so
this woman obviously has an ax to grind
I personally like
hope they sue her because she definitely
signed an NDA and yes violates every
term of that
but here's what she said
um
for the first time she revealed the full
inside story of the breakdown of Olivia
Wilde's relationship with Jason Sudeikis
and her affair with Harry Styles
she said that while Olivia Wilde has
always claimed that her and Jason split
up at the start of 2020 they actually
split 10 months later weeks after she
began began filming with Harry Styles
the nanny said she was caught in the
middle of the warring pair and said that
Jason Sudeikis later uncovered the full
details of Olivia's relationship with
Harry by reading messages on an Apple
watch Olivia had left behind during one
blow up on November 15th Jason allegedly
lashed out in chase after Olivia after
she had prepared a salad for Harry
Styles in their kitchen Jason went
outside and lay under her car so she
wouldn't leave the nanny said a series
of devastating texts from Olivia and
Jason to their Nanny reveals how the
actor was crying crying to her about
Olivia leaving
not the salad yeah
this is so messy I mean Olivia has
stated and really dug her ground for
years not for years but for months that
this was not an extramarital affair she
started dating Harry after Jason and all
was kosher
um I think a lot of people were
skeptical of that and the people who
were skeptical of that now have even
more reason to be skeptical because the
nanny said they were still together
during 2022. it wasn't January it was
more like October
um so that's interesting I don't know
like
this feels like a little too much
information for me like of course people
are entitled to having breakdowns in
their kitchens and fighting with their
husbands in their driveways like I don't
know I feel like as much as I really
wanted to like slurp up this tea it just
really feels like none of our [ __ ]
business right and then also you do have
to question the source and right Olivia
and Jason said like she's been acting
in an unprofessional manner for months
now and like kind of harassing them so
I'm not even sure if everything that she
said was true even if it is true it's
not my business to know so I'm not
really like ingesting it I feel like
when people do stuff in public it's then
it's up for all of us to pick apart yeah
but what you do in the privacy of your
own home this is like a confidentiality
it's like spying and no it's really
people deserve privacy it's like when
you get evidence
in an illegal illegally what's that
called I don't know but like it the
evidence is thrown out because if it was
secured in an illegal manner it's uh no
there's a word it's um
it's like you throw it out it's like uh
hold on
evidence
the thing is with the c
it's like so long order like I know it's
so circumstantial
we've had this conversation once before
and then like afterwards I remembered
what I would what it was and now I'm
forgotten again
[ __ ]
whatever the evidence gets thrown out
because it's neither here nor there
because it was secured in an illegal
manner so I agree like I and I bet
they're you know Elizabeth Elizabeth
Olivia and Jacob oh my God I'm not okay
Elizabeth and Jacob Olivia and Jason are
like probably quaking that this woman
who's clearly unhinged was like so close
to their children for so long like
that's like a pit Beyond pit hit Beyond
pit
so I don't know I don't like this I
really don't and it doesn't really
change how I feel about the situation no
if anything it makes me sympathetic
towards Olivia and Jason right and what
the biggest bombshell would be like that
she did cheat on Jason with Harry that
they did start their Affair well right
well people already think that so
it doesn't change anything for me no I
agree
are you ready for our next story is it
the next story that's brought to you
bye
hiya yeah
typical children's vitamins are
basically candy in Disguise they are
filled with teaspoons of sugar unhealthy
chemicals other gummy junk that Growing
Kids should never eat and that's why
Haya was created it is a pediatrician
approved super powered chewable vitamin
While most children's gummies are filled
with five grams of sugar and can
contribute to a variety of health issues
Haya is made with zero sugar zero gummy
junk but it tastes great and is perfect
for picky eaters like myself Hyatt fills
in the most common gaps in modern
children's diets to provide the full
body nourishment our kids need with a
yummy taste that they love it's
formulated with the help of nutritional
experts Haya is pressed with a blend of
12 organic fruits vegetables and it's
supercharged with 15 essential vitamins
and minerals including vitamin D B12 C
zinc folate and many others to help
support immunity energy brain function
mood concentration teeth bones and more
high as products are non-GMO they are
vegan they are dairy free allergy free
gelatin free nut free and pretty much
everything else you can imagine because
all your kids have different needs and
Haya is looking out for the campers
which we really appreciate it because it
is a camper tested mother approved brand
yes I just got high of gummies and I
think it's such a great idea for a brand
obviously but what's so cute about them
and I got them um I'm giving them to
kaler because they come with like
stickers and stuff that you decorate the
bottle with but like so cute they're
decorated it herself and she was so
excited about it makes the kids like
excited to take their gummies a hundred
percent because you know kids these days
you gotta make [ __ ] exciting because
it's designed for kids of all ages it is
sent straight to your door so your
parents have one less thing to worry
about again the decorating is kind of
the kids favorite parts so so great oh
play with this for 10 minutes while
Mommy goes and takes a shower and has a
glass of wine like it's nice they're
taking care of everyone we have worked
at a special deal with Haya for their
best-selling children's vitamin you can
get 50 off your order if you click claim
the deal you have to go to
highahealth.com toast deal is not
available on their regular website so
you have to go to h y no scratch that h
i y a health
h-e-a-l-t-h.com slash toast again that's
hayahealth.com toast
h-i-y-a-h-e-a-l-t-h.com slash toast get
your kids the full body nourishment they
need to grow into healthy beautiful
stunning and smart adults great okay our
next story Meghan Markle is talking
about her time on Deal or No Deal on her
new podcast finally new episode dropped
with Paris Hilton and she is talking
about her time as the Deal or No Deal
um briefcase quick question
um has she not released an episode since
the last time we talked about it or were
the other episodes like irrelevant I
think that she did release an episode I
think um
I I believe that she did that she has
um so she quit her job in 2006 as a
briefcase girl under no deal because she
felt she was being quote reduced to a
bimbo she said I ended up quitting the
show I was so much more than what was
being objectified on the stage I didn't
feel like I didn't like feeling forced
to be all looks in little substance and
that's how it felt for me at the time
being reduced to this specific archetype
the word bimbo well she is like having
to use the word archetype right she
warning it into every episode but I
think that's the point of this show it's
which episode is what word are we
deconstructing and this one is bimbo
got it okay I mean by the way to be
objectified like that like that sucks
um
but that's kind of like you know
becoming a lawyer and being like you
know there's too many too many trials
for me like that's the job right right
she said I was grateful for the job but
not about how it made me feel which was
not smart by the way I was surrounded by
smart women but that wasn't the focus
no for sure
um
and
I'm glad she's talking about it because
like it's kind of like I kind of by the
way for me another cultural shift moment
was when everybody put together that
Meghan Markle who had just got engaged
to Harry had been on Deal or No Deal
like for me like that whole Arc like you
can that's literally like the American
dream like you can do and become
anything you want it doesn't matter
where you came from so I personally like
I'm obsessed with this Arc
um to hear that she didn't have a
pleasant time like that sucks but it's
also like what did you expect like that
is literally the job you signed up for
like you you don't talk as a briefcase
girl you literally stand there in a tiny
dress yeah and hold the briefcase and
hold the briefcase right
so I'm glad that she's I think feel like
this is the first time since she's been
Royal that she's acknowledged it I think
so I'm trying to get back I I can't
remember no that's why it's so crazy
yeah so and you know what honestly I
that's what a podcast is for I respect
she could have you know kept pretending
like it didn't exist next I need her to
talk about giving road head to Ethan in
90210
next I need to talk about her to talk
about the Hallmark experience
was she in a Hallmark movie yeah
which ones one Sparks Fly it was a very
lovely July 4th Center oh not Christmas
okay that's why it's not Christmas but I
do think that there were others and in
it her romantic lead of Sparks Fly was
Betty Cooper's father from Riverdale
also known as
the black hood yeah Hal Cooper oh that's
weird
that's very weird it's a good movie
though check it out I am so grateful
that she is I mean we never watched but
everyone's obsessed with suits yes I
know I never watched so I don't know
anything
um that's why I didn't mention it but
yes people are so we would be remiss if
we didn't mention it of course of course
even though to me like cultural impact
of Deal or No Deal is just as big as
that of Suits agreed
um so I'm grateful that she is talking
about it because like honestly it's
something I've long wondered and thought
about like what her opinion on it is
it's not high we know we know that now
um and
cool cool yeah
she didn't give us like a lot to work
with but no and her show is like kind of
scripted so it's like
um it's yeah it's like it's
um it's all thought out no it's like
interview and then she talks like not
but I'm pretty sure it's like written
out before yeah yeah no it's like it's
edited it has like an interview style
and then like they cut to like a
narration amusing Megan's music Megan's
musings but it's not like oh [ __ ] did I
just say that [ __ ] yeah no it's not
conversational it's very um produced yes
are you ready for our next story
is it the fourth or the fifth the fourth
I am ready Erica Jane says she was
joking about PK and dorit kemsley being
the next to break up so we reported
yesterday that a Bravo Khan Erica was
asked who she thought the next couple to
break up would be after a long pause she
said to read in PK then PK posted PK
dragged her to [ __ ] filth yes he did
he said Erica Jane thought her husband
was innocent she thought the ankle is
more important than the brain
she thought she could keep the earrings
now she thinks dorit and I are next to
split up here's a quick bit of
management advice stop thinking
yikes you know what's so interesting to
me is like at the beginning of the
season of Beverly Hills garcelle's main
gripe was like there is a core group in
this group and like no one else can
really make genuine friendships because
the five of you are so like tight and
now it's between Lisa and Kyle being
dunzo and Erica and Doreen like that
group of Lisa Kyle
Erica dorit and I think Teddy Mellencamp
was in that too they're like fizzled
like they're done yeah also Erica then
said um when did you get so sensitive
you know damn well I was joking but this
actually reminded me of something and
it's gonna sound like kind of crazy but
throughout this season I was like kind
of getting I don't know what sort of
vibe but I can't explain it between like
Erica and PK like they were such bitter
enemies to read in PK's first season
like and Erica like eviscerated him like
on the reunion he was just like meant to
be like this like pervy weird guy and
now Erica and PK had like a really good
friendship like you always see them like
chatting when there's a party I think
they like
um like each other yeah I think they
like each other even when PK was like to
Mauricio like aside from your wife like
who looks the best tonight remember when
he asked him that yeah of course and he
asked it like waiting to give his answer
of Erica right he had someone in his
brain right and Maurice is like
yeah no totally I just feel like
there it's
they're like really sometimes like are
so
what are you trying to say they just
have like this love-hate relationship
and now they're on the hate side but you
don't get I mean your friend's husband
like that I also don't know why Erica
said it like it I if okay so first of
all I didn't get the vibe at all that
she was kidding yeah
so I I hate when people say that like if
you're gonna say something stand by it
so I don't know why she said it and then
I don't know why she said she was
kidding and it was like how could they
not be upset by that like don't be all
surprised that they're mad no if that's
your friend and that your friend says
that like say about someone you're not
friends with like right because dorit is
like very Switzerland almost to the
point where she's like boring this
season so she doesn't come for anyone if
anything she was being like really
sympathetic to Erica and Aspen so I
don't really know why Erica would come
for her when dorit has really been
nothing but neutral and really nice to
Erica this season yeah
like they moved into Diana's Hotel
together right right so like come on
it's weird it's weird for sure and it's
like it's aggressive for no reason yeah
I don't know but who else would she have
said she was asked which of the ladies
from Beverly Hills right I don't know
what the question was but she would have
stuck to Beverly Hills because she
doesn't know the other franchise's
marriage I mean it's hard to say because
Sutton and garcelle don't have husbands
nobody knows Rick Hilton
she would never say Rina no and she
wouldn't say Kyle and she can't you
can't say Kyla Mauricio because their
marriage is an institution yeah
so she was really only left what to read
not answered she like walked down the
runway yeah she made a moment oh man
yeah
um these watch weapons live specials
have started to air the first night I
sent you that clip they had um
did Candace Dillard Bessette Kenya Moore
Sheena Marie Shea and Melissa Gorga each
perform like a medley of their own songs
and I was like living for every moment
of it I thought um Kenya's was a mess
I thought sheena's was so cute like she
did actually a really good job she did
Candace Dillard took it incredibly
seriously which was like a little bit
weird but still pretty good and then
Melissa Gorga lip sang for her life and
it was fabulous yeah it was
couldn't look away no I mean these watch
weapons live specials they've done them
before and I don't know why they have so
much trouble with the audio like Andy's
running around handing his microphone to
everyone like mic people up yeah
no they did them it's a chaos but I
think like by sheena's turn she realized
you know what just don't sing over the
track because you can't sing you can't
hear it
um Kenya was the first
and she got screwed the first through
the wall is the bloodiest she didn't
know she didn't know yeah and they all
were good sports about it yeah um I
actually really enjoy those watched
weapons live specials where they do like
the kids ones like I like that
yeah I didn't watch it you know what I
started watching a new show on Netflix
called the empress
what's up is it like Royal Vibes it's
Royal Vibes it's um about CeCe she's the
Empress of Austria and she's come up a
lot in my readings I was actually just
reading about Hedy Lamarr and she plays
CeCe in an uh Austrian like Broadway
production of Cece and I was like you
know what I've seen this woman a few
times I'm gonna read a book about her
next and then I realized that this new
show on Netflix is about her so I've
started watching it it's really quite
gorgeous and stunning I'm only two
episodes in but I look forward to
learning her story
stunted
are you ready for our fifth and final
story only if it's the fifth and final
story that's sponsored by neutralfall
yeah is it yeah sorry I was yeah so I
don't know if you guys knew this but 30
million women are impacted by weakened
or thinning hair if you're among them
just know you're not alone and there is
a solution that you can trust to deliver
deliver results millions of Americans
experience thinning hair it is more than
common it's actually considered normal
and it can feel really lonely and
frustrating but it's time to change a
conversation join the thousands of women
who are standing up for their strands
with neutralfall nutrifall is the number
one dermatologist recommended hair
growth supplement that is clinically
shown to improve your hair growth it can
improve thickness it can show visible
scalp coverage it supports healthy hair
from within it targets the five root
causes of thinning which are stress
hormones environment nutrition and
Metabolism through whole body health so
nutrifall has three unique formulas to
support women throughout all stages of
life including postpartum and menopause
each formula is physician formulated
using natural drug free medical grade
ingredients in consistently effective
dosages so that you get the most
reliable results in a clinical study 86
percent of women reported improved hair
growth after six months over three
thousand Top Doctors and stylists
recommend neutrofall as an effective and
high quality solution for healthier hair
so nutrifola has become one of these
brands that you can really trust their
ingredients are premium it is developed
by the best in the world and there's
proven results whatever reason you might
be having hair loss I know you
experience a lot of hair loss postpartum
whatever the reason is some people get
it and menopause some people just get it
in stages in their life when they're
really stressed out
um nutripal is going to Target that
reason whether it's stress whether it's
environment whether it's postpartum
hormones and they are going to Target
that and eradicate your hair loss
um and millions of women are using
neutrophone it's a fabulous brand you
can grow thicker healthier hair and
support the show by going to
neutrophone.com enter promo code toast
to save 15 off your first month
subscription it's the best offer that
they have anywhere and it is only
available to us customers for a limited
time they also offer free shipping on
every order and the 15 off at
nutrifall.com it's spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com that promo code is
toast for 15 off plus the free shipping
on every order Nutra fall
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code toast
our fifth and final story a little more
Bravo news Monique Samuels and her
husband Chris Samuels have taken to
their YouTube channel to address the
rumors and they have announced that they
are trying to fix their marriage but
they deny divorce rumors so you are 100
right by the way like
I thought you were being crazy being
like no they like it's it literally
feels like they put this story out to
promote their YouTube channel it worked
because Monique admitted that her Mac
because if there was no divorce rumors
and then she just went on YouTube to say
that there's no one would care it
wouldn't be news because also they went
on Love and Marriage DC last year and
like talked about some of their marriage
struggles so that yeah anyway she
admitted that her marriage with her
husband Chris Samuels was quote
struggling in some areas but they are
most definitely not getting a divorce
she said it's no secret that Chris and I
have been struggling in some areas of
our marriage and anybody who watched
Love and Marriage DC last year you all
saw the arguments y'all saw everything
that was going on it was a lot of
confusion it was crazy building up to
that 10-year marker of our marriage and
when you've been married that long and
you have things that you're like listen
this is being unmet or I've been unheard
you start to get frustrated and it's
like oh my God is this what life is
going to be like I can't take it anymore
so what you guys saw in love and
marriage was My Cry for Help
anyways they will be living apart right
now though not getting divorced and they
will be working through these issues I
mean it makes me really sad first of all
that like their marriage is having
trouble because I like I looked up to
their marriage I thought they had an
amazing marriage and I really really
hope that they can work through this
but it also makes me sad that they're
resorting to these types of tricks and
staged moments because Monique is better
than this and I feel like honestly she
needs to come back to Housewives for
real I agree I also think like if you
can sit down and do like a YouTube video
with your 100 and who you're like on the
outs with but you guys can like really
talk about how your needs are and being
mad it's like well what if instead of
talking to YouTube you just talked about
your needs like their Community
therapists like I just feel like
it's a bit drastic considering it seemed
of course not everything says it seems
but like to sit down and be able to like
talk publicly about the fact that you
guys are going through a rough time
right now and how rough can it be
divorce it's like we can maybe come back
from here yeah no because couples most
couples 99 of couples who are on the
brink of divorce I cannot even look at
each other let alone sit down and record
a YouTube video right if you need so
much space from someone that they need
to move out like
you're not getting it together to film
right
so what I need for Monique is I need her
and Chris to really work on their
marriage get to a better place so that
they can return yeah
because it's enough like it was fun she
was disrespected she had to stand her
ground but now Bravo needs to
um
swallow their pride and crawl back to
Monique I don't think she's gonna go
back
I know because you know what she is
even though I believe the original
Candace was talking about have you know
Scruples she was talking about Candace
actually she might have been talking
about Ashley for writing the statement
I don't know who Candace was referring
to yeah she was talking like to Chris
Chris but I don't know what it was about
I think it was about Monique
um well we've truly come full circle on
that
um I just I need her back especially
because I know it's early so it's not
fair to say but like these first two
episodes of Potomac have been positively
Dreadful like the way that Giselle is
creating a storyline out of thin air
with this Chris Bassett DM like we need
more we're gonna need more we're gonna
need more than that yeah and I just I
know the woman to do it I think they
thought it was going to be Charisse but
I think it's going to be Monique
I hate Charisse I would love for it to
be Monique I would love for it to be
better so now that Theresa's back
Monique probably won't join right right
right right yeah but like these Antics
with the YouTube and like the
boy who cried divorce like she's better
than this yeah
come on
um so those are the fast five stories
you definitely did not need to know any
of them really
maybe the first one and what you didn't
need to know Jason and Olivia
no you didn't need to know the big
nothing burger that was Monique
uh Meghan Markle also she said a whole
bunch of nothing yeah but she talks
about her time right right maybe okay
it's maybe like two and a half of the
stories you needed to know yeah the
James Corden thing is just like I'm
still trying to
process it because just something about
it just like doesn't
doesn't feel like justice to like
put someone on I don't know but like of
course it does by the way if your crime
is going to be like being an [ __ ] I
think being put on blast is the perfect
punishment honestly it's not illegal to
be an [ __ ] but it's just not the
right thing to do of course of course I
don't know it's just like
it didn't feel like justice I also felt
like the way it ended felt weird yeah
because like apologies to the
restaurateur not he didn't apologize
publicly to MK and G right or to the
staff that we know of so I don't know
it's just like a weird story it was
definitely a weird ending like never
mind he apologized he can come back and
I want to host Late Show yeah no the the
guy is weird
but I respect the hustle because if I
ever like you know if James Corden ever
owed me anything I too would ask in
return to do his job
yeah also now people probably go to
Balthazar like knowing you're gonna be
put on blast so like I'm gonna also
you're gonna see celebrities I'm gonna
be an angel now you know it definitely
adds to like the legacy of Balthazar
which already has like a rich history of
being a celeb spotting where is it
I think it's technically in uh Greenwich
Village it's like I think it's by
Lafayette I think don't quote me on that
I've been once and I took a cab and I
don't remember like what street it was
your actions I don't I don't know if
I've ever maybe no sorry I think it's in
SoHo okay it's a stunning Facility by
the way when you come to town we should
go it's like that next time we have a
gnome we don't know where to go that's
where we should go okay right
oh I will Keith McNally I will
so those were the stories that was our
show nice and quick show oh no it's
already an hour and 10 minutes okay
um
tomorrow we are back with deer toasters
we have any TV that's on tonight
definitely yeah though I couldn't tell
you what no I couldn't tell you either
but we'll see you guys tomorrow thank
you so much for listening to the chose
the Monday Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available it's about a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found on Spotify
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the toast sleep a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are hope you guys have an
incredib Tuesday and we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day bye